Nick is finally asking the question,
"Can I Can I really be defamation saying
things one supports genocide?"
>> In this social climate, I'd say having a
reputation of supporting genocide is
pretty bad.
>> It It's not a tackle I've seen Nick use
before.
Well, I got to say I'm impressed. The
big sweep is on. No might. No might. And
this is a big [music] sweep. Get on a
stream with literally anyone, you
disgusting pig. So, obviously, Ethan
Klein announced his new lawsuit against
Noah Samson for defamation this time,
saying that his video released just over
a year ago now called The YouTubers Who
Backed the Genocide was defamatory. Now,
as you may know, Nicholas Deorio has
been Team Ethan the whole way. And he
actually did give a position on the idea
of Ethan suing Noah just a little while
ago. And we'll break down Nick's initial
position here cuz it'll be relevant for
his coverage. So, if you've ever watched
me cover Nick before, you may be
familiar with a little phrase Nick Nick
likes to use. He'll say, "I don't feel
bad for He'll say, 'It's bad, but I
don't feel bad for.' Or, 'It's bad, but
I have no sympathy for.' Or, 'It could
be bad, but I have no empathy for.' He
uses them interchangeably cuz he doesn't
really know what they mean. He He will
say this all the time. And it's
basically a way for Nick to
simultaneously sound like he's
condemning something by saying it's bad,
could be bad, could have bad effects,
don't know if I'm okay with it, whatever
he's saying, whatever he's priming it
with. And then following it up with a
total undercut of that, a total washing
away of that that makes the previous
part irrelevant, but people still have
it in their mind where he'll say, "But I
just have no sympathy for But I just
don't feel bad for Noah Samson." So,
you're actually saying you do support
it. So, you're actually saying you do
support it, but you've said you're not,
so people people take that. And they're
just like, "See, it's all just He's just
having a laugh. He's just having a No.
No, Nick supports it. Nick supports it,
and he's making the arguments that
support it. And he does that throughout
all of his content. That's it That's his
goal. He is supporting it. So, in this
instance, let's hear what Nick says.
Like I was going to say what he says,
but no, let's just hear it. Let's hear
it straight from the pig's mouth. after
his 20 day mixture subreddit 4 days ago.
Uh has Ethan mentioned if he's going to
go through with suing Noah after his 20
days is up? Uh a week or two ago, I've
watched the episode. I haven't heard
anything about it. Is Ethan not going to
sue him anymore? Now, we covered this
earlier on. I told you that Noah Samson
is a disinformation machine who cockily
just cockily who who has a cocky tone
and [__] lies about people constantly
in his videos. I said that I don't feel
bad for him having to sweat this lawsuit
out. I don't think that Ethan's going to
file a lawsuit on him. If he does,
whatever. I I mean, I don't know.
I'll let you know my actual So, dude,
listen listen to this take. So, Nick is
presented with something that he may
have to disagree with, a defamation
lawsuit, okay? Something that he may,
under any principles he's laid out
before, have to disagree with if he were
being consistent. So, instead of giving
a take, Nick uses this to kick the can
down the road. He says, "Thinking
Ethan's not going to do anything.
Thinking it's an empty threat." He says,
"Uh well, I guess if he does sue him,
whatever. But I'm okay with the threat.
I'm okay with the threat. I get I guess
we'll see how I feel if he ever does
file something, but I don't think he
will, so whatever." We'll fight on the
lawsuit itself once it's filed. But I
think this is a guy who deserves to
sweat. I think a guy who has spread
false pedophile allegations about Chud
Logic uh and then begrudgingly
>> Mr. P though.
Mr. P though himself. Bro.
They're calling this guy a pedophile.
Can you believe it? They're calling this
guy a pedophile. I am Mr. P though,
okay? I'm coming to you as Mr. P though.
Is They're calling this guy a pedophile.
I can't believe it. a little wall
[__] silver. Great effort. Cuz you
have to do all You have to prove to the
judge that you've exhausted every
reasonable and in some cases not so
reasonable attempts to serve them. And
finally, your only option is to serve
them in the press.
After you've exhausted all options, you
Wait.
Serving them in the Is he Is this the
press? What is he talking about? I need
Loss here to hold my hand.
>> Say, "Judge, we've done it."
>> Loss is legitimately disabled, by the
way. That guy is like actually [__]
[__] bro. Loss's videos are so
[__] terrible.
>> everything we can Bro, did you just
write Aryan white? Okay, I'm I'm You
know what? [__] red right is actually
not a bad color.
At least we didn't get Aryan white.
>> It's funny as well, man. Nick actually
does know that Loss's videos are
terrible and the guy is a [__] creep.
Because Nick has had to skip like
segments where Loss is like drolling
over women or some [__] in one of his in
one of his videos. And Nick had to like
hurriedly skip past it. The guy has like
hurriedly skipped past it so Loss wasn't
so wasn't seen as like the new legal
mindset.
find this
>> Loss is here. Hey, Loss, how you doing?
person.
And so you get permission. You take out
an ad
>> to put it in a newspaper in local news.
>> in like the LA Times or wherever,
saying, "Hear ye, hear ye, no
>> Wait, could you do that with a
a billboard?
>> [laughter]
>> Dude Dude, it's just Ethan Klein
pointing, saying, "Noah Samson, I'M
COMING FOR YOU!"
>> OH, WAIT. I went back to this one. Do we
end up Do we finish this clip? let you
know my actual thoughts on the lawsuit
itself once it's filed. But I think this
is a guy who deserves to sweat. I think
a guy who has spread false pedophile
allegations about Chud Logic
and then begrudgingly [__]
eventually conceded after multiple
slight walk backs. Uh yeah, I I mean, I
think that guy kind of deserves to be
scared shitless of a lawsuit coming his
way. I think he absolutely deserves to
sweat. And that's what he's been doing
up allegedly. We'll see it. He's
apparently been sweating quite a bit.
So, uh from that standpoint, somebody
who literally
uh plays fast and loose maliciously with
the truth on purpose, in my opinion. In
my opinion. In my opinion. Um I do think
>> He literally can't even stand on
anything. He can't stand on anything,
man.
>> he deserves to sweat. But I thought from
the very beginning that it was just like
a uh you should take down your thing or
else. I didn't really I still don't
really accept uh or expect Ethan to file
the lawsuit. We'll see. We will
see. Dan Saltman, I made a PowerPoint.
This guy is not going to cover it. I am
I don't know. I maybe I look at it
after.
Last update we got was Noah either moved
or pretended to move houses right at the
deadline. That could cause issues with
serving him a lawsuit. But as far as I
know,
um
trying to dodge a lawsuit that's way
more of a TV show thing than a good
idea.
>> Yeah, I think I think that's it. I think
we got the full clip though. It's all
just
>> pages. Vintage vintage reference.
>> Oh, you
You what? Yeah, it's still irrelevant,
wouldn't you think? Nick, now what was
your take on DarkViper? Can you remind
me?
Nick, could you remind me your take on
DarkViper?
It's good guess it's significantly more,
actually.
You You know what?
We'll look for it. We'll look for it.
What is Nicholas's take on DarkViper?
DarkViper video. Yeah. Let's Let's watch
this. Let's watch just a minute from
here.
>> And to specifically pick the one that
Asmongold directly benefits from because
DarkViperAU flipped the [__] out at Carl
Jabbs. I figured going above and beyond
to becoming an affiliate would be a good
gag when I inevitably make my DarkViper
video. I guaran [__] tee that is the
thing that pissed him off because I
don't like react content. I just think
that DarkViper is a net negative. I
think he's worse than Hassan. I think
he's worse than Asmongold. I think
people who abuse the copyright system
because they're fragile little [__]
and threaten to do multi [__]
overseas lawsuits to silence [__]
criticism because their whole dream is
to get the copyright [__] ruling in a
court of law and change fair use for
everybody else.
I think that person is dangerous. I
think that person is a bad person. And I
think that their footprint is worse than
any lazy reactor who's stealing content.
Yes, I think Asmongold is the lesser of
two evils. And I would gladly send him
my percentage to buy this PC just to
flip you off cuz I think it's funny. Cuz
I think it's really funny.
A little bit of a crazy A little bit of
a
crazy clip there, don't you think? A
little bit of a wild clip of Nick saying
some wacky stuff there, don't you think?
Yeah, a lot of this is just pure coal,
guys. I I have to skip through some of
it cuz yeah, Nick's streams are just
like total coal.
But I skipped a bit.
>> There's no
There's no nuance to the discussion.
You're either for the existence of
Israel or you're a Zionist. The
defendant's defamatory video seeks to
prove as a Oh, yeah, that was brilliant.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Let's wind it back.
Dude, I forgot about that.
>> say it. Like Israel shouldn't from a no
dressing.
If you don't concede to the point that
Israel should be disbanded, then I think
that that is usually the
That's usually the main factor for most
people.
And that's that's that's what it takes,
basically, to be to be branded an enemy.
Disbanded. Yeah, that's like a nice way
to say it. Like Israel shouldn't exist.
If you don't say that Israel shouldn't
exist, then you Hebrews you might as
well just be a complete Zionist.
There There's no
There's no nuance to the discussion.
You're either for the existence of
Israel or you're a Zionist. The
defendant's defamatory video seeks to
prove as a So,
obviously,
being a Zionist means
that you believe Israel has a right to
exist. That you that you believe there
should be
a Jewish state in the Levant
as a homeland for the Jews.
That's Israel.
And Nick is saying to these people, "If
you just believe Israel should exist,
you're a Zionist." Well, what a cra-
what a crazy thing for him to think.
What a cra- What a crazy thing for Noah
Samson to be arguing. Well, that guy
must be totally insane. That guy must be
totally [__] insane. That guy must be
some kind of crazy terrorist or
something.
quite imply
for cuz like for American polls, there
are polls that will just say like most
Jews believe America Israel has a right
to exist as a Jewish state. So, that
would be Zionism.
Uh it's interesting that factual matter
that Ethan advocates for the genocide of
Palestinians.
Rather, he made videos talking about
online drama. Along with attacking cons
Yeah, it was like dude, it was a perfect
storm of like, "Hey, the current thing
to pretend to care about is the
Israel-Palestine conflict, right?"
And there are YouTubers who are getting
completely [__] on for it. So, the
easiest target that we could go after,
of course, would be to target the
YouTubers and rope them in, and then we
could [__] them with we can bring you in
with the YouTubers and [__] you with
like boring Israel-Palestine stuff that
you weren't actually signing up for. You
got it? But they did sign up for They
did sign up for it. They did sign up for
it. You sign up for the backlash you get
from your opinions when you state those
opinions. and anti-woke content. After
October 7th, Samson suddenly became a
self-styled ex-Jew [__] idiot. in the
Israel-Palestine conflict. Sorry, I
don't know how to say Al-Khatib
Al-Khatib. My question is, and this is
where I this is where it starts to lose
me a bit.
Is it actually [__] defamation to say
this person supports genocide?
Like, is that
Wow, what a great question to ask him
like 2 hours into your coverage.
I I I guess it this whole thing weighs
on like how much you think supports
genocide does reputational harm, and
whether Ethan can prove
>> Two two hours into your coverage and and
then like a year after this lawsuit
threat was made,
Nick is finally asking the question,
"Can Can there really be defamation
saying things someone supports
genocide?" Wow, man. That This is
high-test stuff, bro. prove it's from
Noah, right? Or does he have to? That
would be a question I have for Lust.
Does Lust have to prove that this is
actually done harm to Ethan and not like
all the other stuff that he said uh to
like Denims and Frogan and Hasan. Like,
is that where the hate's coming from or
is it coming from Noah's video? Thank
you. By calling him a pro-Israel gen- In
this social climate, I'd say having a
reputation of supporting genocide is
pretty bad. genocide collapse
>> people say that I support genocide all
the time, and my life hasn't been
[__]
But again, that's just my personal
testimony.
Raymond that lies for money to help is
Israel genocide these people. What a
horrible [__] thing to say about a
Gazan refugee? Like, how dare you? They
lost sponsors over the hate, right? you,
Nick. And I'm not I'm not saying that
they were unscared, but my question is,
how do you determine that they lost
sponsors over Noah's video?
Or like, how can you prove it was Noah's
video? Dude, they they'd been getting
called a [__] Zionist genocide
support or whatever for over a year
before Noah's video came out. And not
all of the other active Israel-Palestine
related drama that they were already a
part of by the
>> Well, crazy suggestion. This was a
This was a huge like this is
post-content nuke. If this [__]
bastard lost losses disagreeing with
this, then that should be an immediate
red flag that he has no idea what he's
talking about.
>> where at least a segment of every stream
talks about stuff. That's just my
question.
How dare you speak like This is what the
trial's for to prove that? Sure. Yeah,
but again, they don't I don't think that
Ethan Klein signs up for lawsuits that
he doesn't think he can win.
So, I would assume they're not like
They think they can prove it, right?
That's the point. that They don't need
the like the
What? They're looking for the judgment,
but I don't think they need the
judgment. They I don't think they would
go through the entire effort to sue this
guy and track him down for a year for a
coin flip. Dude from San Diego who never
even Again, if you talk to a lawyer and
they tell you it's a long shot, usually
it's like not a good idea to go for the
lawsuit. Initially depicts four online
content creators, Ethan, Mutahar.
There's Mutahar.
Dude, Mutahar full docs is in here. This
arbiter of truth,
this champ Dude, they're going to The
only takeaway is that Ethan is defending
Destiny in the court of law. That's
going to The contextless [__]
takeaway from this. Palestinian people.
After criticizing Dude, Painkillers
Anonymous Destiny? Who's PKA Destiny?
Out of retaliation, Samson changed the
thumbnail. Slapping my name right now.
>> adopted SLAPP though. These laws vary
from state to state. Forgive me if I'm
incorrect here, but isn't California
like the one like they have anti-SLAPP
in California though.
of the defamatory video to This is in
Orange County. included image of
Lonerbox. How [__]
insane is that? This guy
>> [laughter]
>> He really thinks this I mean, this this
is like a really shitty thing to do.
Yeah.
>> I'm sorry. I just I just watched
Lonerbox's uh coverage
of this of the video, and he 110%
deserves to get added to the thumbnail
of the video called the YouTubers who
backed the genocide that features these
people. He belongs in that lineup. He
belongs in this thumbnail with this
title.
He was saying some absolutely stupid,
heinous [__] like a [__] idiot acting
mad confident trying to talk down.
He deserves being there.
YouTubers who backed the genocide, and
then it's just Lonerbox, Destiny, Tom,
and Mutahar. flipping And Ethan's like
soy soy face poking it.
silly accusation Okay, this is the
epitome of like the brain-dead freak on
Twitter who's like, "What do you mean?
You don't like Hasan [__] You must
love dead Palestinians."
to throw around, right?
Yo, come on. Not now.
I'm kidding, Morgan. You okay?
Just imagine that,
>> [laughter]
>> thinking that calling someone backing a
genocide is such a frivolous accusation.
Dude, I love that picture.
>> Lonerbox wishes he was a Jew. Nick is
just cattle. Nick is just straight-up
cattle.
Sure, Mutahar, too. that you just add
people on a whim because they talked
[__]
>> like propagandized to [__] and he's
like, "I guess I guess everyone just
hates Jews now. I guess everyone just
hates I guess everyone just hates Jews
now."
about you.
>> [laughter]
>> Seems bad faith.
Um
Dude, you just [__] saw Tom and
you're like, "Wait a minute." yourself
careful.
>> They let him put BWC on the thumbnail?
Good one. Careful's appreciate you. Hey,
Teddy, thank you. I appreciate you, fam.
to do was secretly hire thousands of
people to testify that they unsubscribed
>> Wait, yeah, yeah, yeah. Wait, what did
you just call that? on the thumbnail.
Um
Dude, you just [__] saw Tom and
you're like, "Wait a minute." yourself
careful.
>> him put BWC on the thumbnail? Good one.
Yeah, as I said last night, Nick has
adopted an unconventional play here
where in order to avoid addressing the
substance of the argument in the
defamation lawsuit he's covering,
he is he is choosing to fixate and
fantasize on his friend's [__]
Um It It's not a tactic I've seen Nick
use before.
Well, I got to say I'm impressed. I've
got it I I'm impressed. We're
breaking new ground here.
Careful's appreciate you. Hey, Teddy,
thank you. I appreciate you, fam. to do
was secretly hire thousands of people to
testify that they unsubscribed
>> put BWC on the thumbnail. Good one.
Careful's appreciate you. Hey, Teddy,
thank you. I appreciate you, fam. to do
was secretly hire thousands of people to
testify that they unsubscribed from H3
cause of Noah like a secret operation.
>> [laughter]
>> A true and correct screenshot of the
thumbnail for the title
is depicted below.
The Nazi Despite Lonerbox not appearing
in the video at all. Yeah, that's
another one.
>> to Wait, do I get more airtime in that
from my own video popping up than
Lonerbox gets or is he not Is his
thumbnail is not included? It's a nice
touch, isn't it?
ending any of these people as
I'm not an expert on how to nice touch,
isn't it?
ending any of these people
as I have 5 seconds, I think. I'm not an
expert on how the body of work of any of
these people's coverage
on Israel-Palestine, right?
Yeah, it's like ignores the Nazi salute
involvement
in a thumbnail called the YouTubers who
backed the genocide. I know what I said
and what I didn't say.
Dude, the only YouTuber I know who
hasn't backed a genocide is Vaush.
Because dude, Vaush
bro
video below. scribed from H3 cause of
Noah like a secret operation.
>> [laughter]
>> A true
and correct screenshot of the thumbnail
for the title
is depicted to
So, it doesn't even like in this
the any of these does it actually lay
out how it's defamatory? Cuz this hasn't
laid out how it's defamatory at all.
below.
The Nazi Despite Lonerbox not appearing
in But they do lay out earlier in the
lawsuit that it's a Nazi salute. Does he
see that bit?
Where in the lawsuit is that?
No, it is here. It is here. Initially
depicts four online content creators,
Ethan, Mutahar.
There's Mutahar.
Dude, Mutahar full docs is in here. This
arbiter of truth,
this champ Dude, they're going to The
Dude, what happens that he skips
uh dude.
Okay, you can never you can literally
never prove this is intentional because
of how he's done it.
But man, does it look mad [__]
suspicious.
So,
he says,
"Skipping because Mutahar full docs is
here. It's not. Mutahar's full docks are
there. This is Mutahar Anas. Everyone
knows that's Mutahar's name. Mutahar's
public with his name. No Nobody is
confused about what Mutahar's name is.
He's very public He's public with his
name.
Mutahar's name is Mutahar Anas. That is
public. That is public information. It's
been public information for years. And
Nick must know as much. Nick Nick must
know that. Nick must know that. Wasn't
he in the Counter-Strike's video at one
point?
Nick must know that. But he says, "Dude,
Mutahar full docks in here." Skips 30
seconds as if he's trying to get away
from Mutahar's name, but skips to a
point where Mutahar's name is still on
the screen, but has skipped the part
where Ethan claims that it's a Nazi
salute in the thumbnail.
Then the second time that Ethan says
it's a Nazi salute, Nick is pausing
repeatedly and says something about
Tom's dick. This whole segment, the
first defamatory claim, he has
completely avoided evaluating. He's
completely avoided evaluating.
Mutahar Anas isn't even his name.
There's one more thing in there for full
government names as in the
Counter-Strike's. Counter-Strike's was
Mutahar Anas? Was that name in one of
your videos that this piggy watched?
Please answer me that question. In one
of the videos that this piggy watched of
yours, did it include the name Mutahar
Anas? It's public. Is it in one of your
videos though?
Is it one of your videos though?
Because that is Nick has 100% seen it if
it is. I'm sure I showed you his
LinkedIn.
I am so sure Nick knows that's public. I
am so sure Nick knows that's public.
This is crazy. This is crazy. Dude, when
Augie comes back, if he is not talking
about all this stuff, the big sweep is
on. No way. No way.
No way.
The big sweep is on. And this is a big
sweep. This one needs a big
sweep, okay?
Trust me. And he called it soy poking
before. Yeah, is it No evaluation of the
claim.
Dude, I just can't believe it. I can't
believe the brazenness. And you can
never prove it. You can never prove it.
Dude, it's crazy, man. It's crazy. And
that's the thing as well, is he can do
this
and he could literally This is what he
could do. He could do this in last
night's stream.
Wait to see what the reaction is over
the next 24 hours to the lawsuit. If
everyone's against it, he just gets on
stream and says, "Oh, no, it's not a
Nazi salute."
Because he's kicked the can down the
road. Just like when he says,
"I'm okay with the threat. I'll see what
I think when the lawsuit comes out. Oh,
I don't know how I I don't know how I
feel about" This is something he said.
These are all quotes.
"I don't know how I'll feel about
Ethan's copyright lawsuits until they
until they drop. I think I'm going to be
principally against it, but there are
ways he can win me." Never explains how
he got one. Never explains how he got
one.
Um
Talks about the the snark DMCA's. Says,
"Oh, I'll look into that one day. I'll
look into that one day. I'll look into
that one day." Still has never actually
looked into it. Still has never actually
looked into it. Just endless examples of
where he's done this.
And people will just play [__] stupid
or play defense. It's crazy, man. Augie
will sit there and go, "I don't know,
man. He's just trying not to [__] up his
bag. He's just trying not to [__] up his
bag."
Dude,
Speaking for my involvement in a
thumbnail called the YouTubers backed a
genocide, I know what I said and what I
didn't say.
Um I didn't I didn't say I backed a
genocide, so you can't say that about
me. The [laughter] only YouTuber I know
who hasn't backed
>> Legitimately childish. It is actually
just childish.
>> backed a genocide is Vaush.
Because dude Vaush
Bro, side perspective Vaush was I think
guys, we're going to quick shill as
well.
>> He actually got banned from Twitch
because of how pro-Palestine he was.
These people are capable only side
profile. I don't know where current
profile Vaush stands on the issue. of
defending themselves and they have
And I what He's like literally No, you
you actually do know where current Vaush
sits. Because the reason you just
brought that up is cuz you saw that
Vaush clip on Twitter, but you're trying
to pretend you haven't because I posted
it. We all know what's happening because
you do it to other people. And you
literally have to take throwaway tweets
and cut out throwaway and put them on
your stream without the name on there
because you're so desperate to avoid
giving Twitter accounts you don't like
any attention. But that's okay, Nick.
We'll let that slide for now. [__] them
too.
Well,
The [snorts] second defamatory statement
is Samson's false factual assertion that
Ethan spreads atrocity propaganda.
>> Yeah, I remember, dude. If you're Dude,
if you comment on my videos and streams,
you might end up in one of these lawsuit
[__] uh things. Someone just said, "I
I'm looking forward to seeing the legal
back and forth over this." I was
surprised one of my comments on your
stream ended up in the defamation
>> the first like, you know, time you see
like chat's names or something in a
lawsuit, it's like, "Ha, isn't that
funny?"
It's such a boring [__] observation
by the like third or fourth time.
someone
He shares the
>> I forgot that Denim's lawyer put me in
there, didn't he? He put my my chat in
there.
mass rape hoaxes. The same hoax that was
used by the Western media, the US
government, and the Israeli government
to justify genocide. Good luck with that
one in court, kid.
That one might work real cute on TikTok
and
Twitter, but good luck proving that mass
rape was a hoax.
That it was atrocity prop Hold on.
Second defamatory statement is Samson's
factual assertion that Ethan spread
atrocity propaganda. He shares the Hamas
mass rape hoaxes.
Um So,
would he have to prove that Hamas
mass rapes were a hoax
to explain?
Let me just look at the timestamp of the
video. Let me hear what he Yeah,
famously that's how defamation case
works cases work, isn't it?
You have to when someone sues you for
defamation in the United States,
you have to prove that what you're
saying is true.
That's how That is how it works, Nick.
Very true. Very smart.
>> he actually said. Cuz I don't understand
why
>> Say a 30-year-old man, by the way. This
guy's [__] 30 years old, dude. he
would have to
defend that point
in particular.
Um It's a [__] 30-year-old.
>> Where is this? The genocide YouTubers
responded
Noah Samson
the YouTubers who backed a genocide.
More of them. I don't. All right, 41:15.
Let's just listen to what this clip is.
Right here.
And burn that
>> Oh, 43:15, sorry. 43:15.
and Israel the broader media system that
allowed this to happen. Let's not return
to Ethan's video. In the content nuke,
you can find just about every type
You're about to clutch me throwing out
the 30-year-old slur. I understand
defamation law to a way better extent
than this, so it doesn't count cuz
that's the point I'm making is that he
does not understand things considering
his age. And I I actually do, so [__]
you.
[__] you.
And I'm not that close. hype of what we
just looked at in terms of manufacturing
consent. Ethan spreads atrocity
propaganda. He shares the Hamas mass
rape hoaxes. This
Okay, and now I'm under Okay, I got it.
I got it. Bazinga. I understand why he
would have to he would have to defend it
being a hoax.
propaganda. Good luck with that one in
court.
>> Dude, dude.
Please explain this to me. What What
just happened in Nick's head, okay?
So, Nick is asking himself the question.
He asks,
"Would Noah Samson
have to prove that the mass rape claim
is a hoax in court?" That's the question
he asked himself.
To find an answer to that,
he pulls up a clip of Noah Samson saying
it's a mass rape hoax.
And he determines, "Yes, Noah Samson
would have to prove that in court."
What went on in his head there? Please
explain Someone explain to me the
[__] reasoning
that was go that was rattling around in
this guy's dome
to figure that one out. I I truly I'm
lost. I don't understand how how he's
even processing stuff. He was hungry.
Well, luckily you have a lot of
bathrooms. Cuz I'm just curious, does
this just feel like it's like a not not
a step too far per se,
but like
at this
I'm starting to Dude, he's like so
scared of saying anything, bro.
Does this just feel like it's like a not
not a step too far
>> out? Is there a way out? Bro, is there a
way out here? At this
I'm starting to feel like we're
listening to the fifth girl's story a
little bit here.
This one, I don't know.
Nikolai
>> Nikolai I'm the one on the I've
explained that.
Uh Ethan's got to catch them all.
I'm surrounded by them at all times.
>> [laughter]
>> Why do you think I don't want to leave
my house?
Makes sense. It feels like he's testing
the boundary.
Anyway,
>> Because I'm not I'm still not convinced
that this was necessary. Protein up.
>> Wow, brave.
Nick pushing the button. Oh, that's
Nick.
>> This salami's actually fire. Carnivore
diet will fix that.
>> This salami mogs
>> Still not convinced, guys. He's He's
just
more kicking the can down the road
endlessly. Nick, the information is
there for you. Nick, the claims are
made. Frankly, the claims were made like
a year ago. But the the actual, you
know, in in writing claims are made now,
right there in front of you, Nick. You
can simply evaluate them and decide.
It's really that [__] easy, actually.
But you're choosing not to. You're
making, once again,
the active choice not to because you are
a
despicable [__] grifter. Besides the
nuke.
The video
I mean, I don't even like the guy, but
he should like if this was the reaction
from Chud Logic and Chud Logic had this
much money when he was doing all the
pedo [__] to Chud,
when he's making like the claims about
Chud's like relationships and stuff. Uh
not relationships, the people he was
talking to on Discord and [__] If this
was the result of that,
I'd be like, "Yeah, go go get him. [__]
him."
Let's just uh juxtapose that with a
different clip.
The bottom line is it's good enough to
pass frivolousness, and now will have to
spend tens of thousands to defend
himself. He's getting [__] up
financially.
And I think that's bad.
And I've got every reason to enjoy
watching Noah Samson get hauled over the
coals, but I don't because I think it's
wrong. I think it is wrong
for someone to face financial
consequence for stating opinions on the
internet. I think it's [__]
Yes, someone in chat said it earlier.
Turn your brain off and enjoy Noah
getting [__]
What a what an absolutely [__]
worthless contribution, man. What a
worthless contribution to all of this.
Turn your brain off. Oh yeah. Wow, Noah
Samson. Yeah, [__] you. It's wretched.
It's like you can't see past your own
nose because of your vengeance
parasocial obsession.
What does it
Who's next? Who's next with all this
[__]
And it might not
Wow, crazy. Crazy.
What I use this one as well.
As Mr. I am Mr. Pido, okay? I'm coming
to you as Mr. Pido. Let's wind it back.
Is he getting into a take? Is he getting
into a take? Let's hear it.
Holy [__] man.
>> Oh no, I'm not that I'm not in chat.
>> Leave me alone, man. Oh, it'd be great
if you abused the legal system.
I don't like that one. I'm that [__]
funny. Uh the taky on the issue is that
laughing at you ain't even funny. That
shit's just cold, bro. That shit's just
straight cold.
Have fun Have fun having sex with robots
or whatever you're doing over there,
buddy.
Noah Samson, wake up. Any other mic up
here cuz they can
You're being sued.
All right. So anyway, we talked about
that.
It's not abuse. Punishing your opponent
is inherent to civil law. Bro, if you
don't have a case and you're just like,
"I'm a rich guy stepping on somebody."
And you don't even think you're going to
win, that is absolutely [__] abuse.
That's crazy. That would be that would
be nuts.
Um
Whether Ethan
supports genocide is a proof
>> That's so America coded. Yeah.
>> accusation, true or false.
And as I explicitly stated in the nuke,
I condemned Israel's treatment. Samson
engaged in similar conduct explic- ex-
yeah.
Explic- ex- expressly misrepresenting
contents of the video to falsely assert
that Anas and Turkey Tom Oh, that's a
Mutahar support Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people as well.
The defamatory
>> So you're just going through like all
this stuff here.
Um video entitled "Twitch Is
Disgustingly Evil Platform", a Mutahar
video, defamatory video, and the Anas
video, he explicitly states, "I am not
somebody who's afraid to say that
genocide is wrong." That is afraid to
say that
Wait.
Yeah, just 20 minutes ago this guy is
saying that's Mutahar's full docs.
Twitch is disgusting support Israel's
genocide of the Palestinian people as
well.
assert Didn't
that Anas and Turkey Tom Oh, that's a
Mutahar support Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people as well.
defamatory
>> So you're just going through like all
this stuff here.
Um video entitled "Twitch Is
Disgustingly Evil Platform", a Mutahar
video, defamatory video, and the Anas
video, he explicitly states, "I am not
somebody who Dude.
So
>> [laughter]
>> Bro,
come on.
Again, you can literally you can never
prove this is the case. You can never
prove it's intentional.
But holy [__] he has shown Mutahar's
full name in a video before and not even
full name, but Mutahar and Anas, that
name. He showed He's shown that in a
video before. He's shown his son saying
it. He heard his son saying it. He
showed a legal letter with it on.
He sees it here. He skips it the first
time, conveniently skipping also the
part where Ethan claims that uh the
content nuke pose is a is a Nazi salute,
the pose that he was he was doing for
his thumbnails a Nazi salute.
Um
He conveniently skips that part, but
leaves Mutahar's full name on screen.
Despite and claims it's the full docs
despite having already shown on his
stream previously and uploaded the video
segment with it fully uncensored.
Then 20 minutes later,
he sees the name again.
He doesn't skip.
He reads it out. He says Mutahar and
Anas. He says Mutahar and Anas.
What conclusion What conclusion,
seriously, are you supposed to draw
other than that skipping it was
intentional and he's deliberately
avoiding it because he knows it's a
[__] weak losing point. Possibly
even influenced by the fact he got so
much [__] for the swastika sword thing.
Just uh that's that's
total schizo theory though.
who's afraid to say that genocide is
wrong. That is afraid to say that
genocide is wrong. I think there's an
actual case of, you know, Wasn't that
video in response to it though?
Like after the fact? I guess cuz
he responded to it.
Uh Israel good or Palestinian good or
Palestinian bad or Israel bad. Like it's
not my take here. I just think that
like, you know, civilians dying is sad
and unfortunate and I don't like that.
You know, civilians aren't the
government, they're not militants,
they're not soldiers. They're just
living somewhere where they were born
and grew up. So obviously, you know, I'm
I'm going to feel bad for them
if they die.
Despite expressly stating his sympathies
for Palestinian civilians losing their
lives, Samson labels Turkey Tom as a
supporter of Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people.
Again, just proving like
you can criticize someone's take
without jumping to the The first
defamatory statement also portrayed
Lonerbox, who is Lebanese, as a
supporter of Israel's genocide of the
Palestinian people.
This has to be the second video then cuz
Lonerbox wasn't in the first one. They
just added him to the thumbnail, right?
Um yeah, that has to be the second one.
No. that
This note, if you paid any [__]
attention, [__] so skipping off a
video, you would know the first
defamatory statement refers to the
thumbnail and the title of the video
"The YouTubers Who Backed the Genocide".
So when he says the first defamatory
statement also falsely portrayed
Lonerbox, he's referring to the
thumbnail and title
of the "YouTubers Who Backed the
Genocide" video.
His coverage sucks so [__] bad, dude.
Genuinely, you will never get good
information watching this guy about any
drama
because he's just a vapid [__] [__]
through and through. He is so [__]
stupid.
This has to be the second video then cuz
Lonerbox wasn't in the first one. They
just added him to the thumbnail, right?
And a dishonest scum like Yeah, that has
to be the second [__] lowlife. He is
just a total [__] lowlife.
>> would be why the second video would be
relevant to that cuz I missed that part.
Because it would be in response to the
first video, so the second video pops up
now. Many of you can probably also help
out with that.
>> It's crazy, bro. Cuz most of you have
smartphones. You have no idea what's
going on. So go ahead. He has no idea
what's going on and he skips things that
are damaging to his case. It's
disgusting. This guy is such a lowlife,
such a disgusting [__] reprobate.
Truly, man.
Get on a stream with literally anyone,
you disgusting pig. Get on a stream with
Peisko. Get on a stream with me, you
disgusting lowlife [__] pig.
Holy [__]
>> Start posting about it. Spread the word.
Aside from being a morally good thing to
Yeah, this is the clip. Do we have the
timestamp of this? In 1 Okay, this is
the one that I was like, "Oh, okay,
you're kind of giving the game away
here, buddy."
1:01:36.
Which video was this, bro? Which is the
defamatory video for this?
Is this 1:01:36?
>> apology that he adheres reached pretty
wide audiences. And Yeah, listen to this
one.
>> And Bad Empanada has done a fantastic
job with that. His videos have reached
pretty wide audiences and exposed them
to uh the reality and history of the
genocidal Zionist project. That's a
really good thing. That's a really
important thing that he's doing, and I
think many [clears throat] of you can
probably also help out with that. Most
of you have smartphones and cameras and
TikTok. So go ahead. Start posting about
it. Spread the word. Aside from being a
morally good thing to do, it's also
becoming sustainable, you know. Yeah,
it's like, "Oh guys, we need to reach a
larger audience. Let's use these people
to backpack our message. [__] their
reputations. [__] their names.
Uh and and [__] what happens to them."
They Are we really trying to pull the
same [__] [__] as the
uh malicious side of the abuse thing
where they were where Daniel wasn't even
saying that in the first place? He's
obviously not saying go and lie about
these people, is he, [__] [__] He's
saying people's attention is on the
slop.
Use that to introduce something that's
more important that that that widens
their perspective.
It's what he's saying. That's what he's
saying.
What's wrong with that? Contest that.
Condemn that.
Lay out a criticism, you stupid pig. in
association with us being crazy [__]
uh militant
>> [laughter]
>> Palestine supporters is a nice way to
put it. It's algorithmically viable.
It's algorithmically viable to take your
take your enemy and place them at the
forefront of genocide.
>> crash out industrial complex is booming,
and we can harness it as a propaganda
machine to
Dude, we can harness the Ethan Klein
industrial complex as a propaganda This
is the clip I've been talking about all
stream.
>> Okay, what's the problem with that?
What's the problem with that?
Where I'm like this is I think this is
the moment where if he does lose and if
this is like a legit lawsuit, he's I
think this [__] him. No? expose Zionism
for the genoc-
Yes, Nick. If you If you have already
proved
that
he has
not only gotten something wrong,
but intentionally gotten something
wrong,
then on top of that, you you might be
able to say, "And look, here's him
essentially laying out to to sweeten it
a little bit." You might you might be
able to use that.
But you would first have to prove that
anything he said was wrong.
Then you Sorry, sorry. We're not not
even that. Sorry. First you would have
to prove that it's not opinion, that
it's that it's actually a statement of
fact.
Then you would have to prove that it is
false.
Then you would have to prove that Noah
Samson made that false statement knowing
it to be false.
And then, maybe, somewhere along the
way, Nick, you could use this clip.
Maybe. Maybe.
and the side ideology that it is. You
may have the
>> This is the video where he slammed all
these people in the title to get more
views on his video, in my opinion.
>> feeling is I often have that the history
books will look back upon these times
and those who supported the Gaza
genocide with shame and horror. Well,
proving damages, prove damages or
convince the court that it's a valid per
se claim. Cuz Ethan is filing it as a
per se claim, right? So prove damages or
get it accepted per se.
Right? I think that's right. Isn't it?
Um the only problem with that is that
these people feel no shame. They're here
to make And again, this is something
that's important, too, I guess, is that
I don't know how much damage is done by
this video,
but it sounds like he wanted some.
>> [laughter]
>> It sounds like he's like, "Dude, history
will remember you, [__] dis- Yes, but
wanting damage isn't necessarily malice.
Wanting damage
not necessarily malice. Because Noah
wants wants damage because he thinks
it's advancing the goal. He is saying,
"Advance this goal. Damage is entailed
by that,
but advance this goal." Is he saying,
"Lie?"
No.
No. He is saying, "Go out there, produce
propaganda for this cause."
Does that damage Ethan? Yes.
Is that malice? No.
honorably because I have decided these
are your positions
and you won't care about them, which
sucks.
>> make money and to convince themselves
that they aren't evil. And the way they
do that is by lying, by spreading
>> sounds like he wants these people to be
financially destitute because he's
saying that
>> do? make money and to convince
themselves that they aren't evil. And
the way they do that is by lying, by
spreading
>> sounds like he wants these people to be
financially destitute because he's
fabricated their thoughts. liberal
Zionist propaganda. It's profitable and
it's easy and it's acceptable. You're
allowed to say that you think all
Palestinians should die
>> I'm pro-genocide.
>> and still get invited to Jubilee as the
resident liberal. You're allowed to do
it and and run your quirky epic stream
podcast.
>> thoughts on that?
Any thoughts on that? You seem to have a
whole lot of perspectives on how
anti-Semitic Hasan [__] is and how he
thinks Israel how it's disgusting that
people think Israel should be wiped off
face of the map, yet you have nothing to
say when you're presented with a clip of
Destiny saying, "I'm pro-genocide."
And obviously the rest of that clip is,
>> [music]
>> "I'm pro-genocide, something something.
I think the Palestinians probably just
get out of there. I'm sorry, that's just
how it is." Or some [__] like that.
Thank you very much, Mr. Gotti. Thank
you.
hundreds of thousands of dollars doing
that because the Western media ecosystem
encourages it. There will be no justice
for the Palestinian people if all we do
is watch content about what's happening.
Consumption is not
>> Like is it that hard to just make your
video
on YouTube without dragging everybody
into it?
I don't know.
He's responding to the content, you you
stupid [__] Dude, it's also becoming
sustainable, you know? It's
algorithmically
>> All of you retards supported the
content, you. [__] like Tom went out
there and said [__] about
Israel-Palestine for no [__] reason.
Say stupid [__] that makes him sound 60
IQ, rambling about, "Oh, I'm always
going to feel bad for civilians when
they die." able the Ethan Klein crashed
out industry complex is booming.
>> This is the clip that he did that's
probably the worst.
That is not
>> know anything about the law, but if I
did, I would say that this is like akin
to the statement from the Denims
lawsuit.
Um or the Frogan lawsuit or the [__]
Casey Tron lawsuit, where they were
saying like I don't know, or whoever
said don't They literally He knows it's
literally
He's trying to come up He's nervous
about saying this cuz he knows the
statements have actually been criticized
now. He knows that me, J Stovall, Pisco,
everyone has criticized the actual
statements that are being claimed to be
malicious side-thing.
Nervous about what he's going to say
here. So he sits there, once again, full
sip, gulp, every [__] time cuz he's
got no poker face despite hiding behind
a [__] avatar cuz he's a fat
disgusting [__]
No poker face, gulping as he tries to
get through this [__] sentence. Oh,
this is like when when the bad woman
said
Oh, let's hear what he says. Let's hear
what he says, stupid bastard. give them
views or whatever.
Or the snark thread. A very good dead.
lawsuit, where they were saying like
I don't know, or whoever said don't give
them views or whatever. Whoever said
don't give them views or whatever.
Whoever said
doesn't attribute it to a specific
person,
doesn't use specific quotes,
ends it with whatever to or whatever to
indicate that he has no idea what he's
saying. And then on top of that,
changes the group that he's attributing
it to to the snark thread, to the snark
thread. So now it's not even a statement
by one of the parties being sued in the
[__] lawsuits. It's It's about the
[__] collaboratory copyright damage
now, which is like this totally
unproven, like barely tested statute
that Ethan's relying on.
It's amazing. It's truly [__] amazing
how bad this guy's coverage is, truly.
All right, so we've got more defamatory
statements going through here.
>> The other thing that's important,
though, Nick.
>> to talk about anything else other than
just reading what he's suing him over. I
get that The other thing that's
important, though, Nick.
>> of the point of the segment, but
But what?
>> It doesn't
But what, Nick? BUT WHAT?
BUT WHAT?
NO, that is the point of the segment.
really mean much to me, I guess, cuz I I
kind of know.
Oh, well, if you know, Nick,
why bother covering it?
If you already know, then why bother
covering it? Why bother covering it? Who
cares? Why engage with any of it?
This is amazingly bad. Once you get
through, this is the issue is Nick's
[__] is like totally unwatchable cuz
he's like absolute [__] coal Family
Guy [__] dick jokes like 90% of the
run time.
But the few moments where he almost
engages,
you really do get a
an amazing piece of content, frankly.
>> based off of
Like you kind of get the gist of this
within two citations. I don't need to
read them all.
>> Right.
>> then points out the following facts
about the
>> the gist, Nick?
>> They recruit They recruit Yeps, there's
more of this.
>> in Yemen And I kind of want to hear
Lasse's perspective on it, too, cuz he
would know better than me. Human rights
organization Watana found that the
Houthis minority I think that might be
barely true. I think that might barely
be true.
Scholar.
>> [applause]
>> Did you go back to it later?
Chat said you should have read that with
the jugs. True. Why are you telling me
that now only?
>> [laughter]
>> Oh my god.
What if that ends Okay.
I think that's all we're getting now as
retards.